and welcome to punch trunks for New Year
everybody we're winners win Happy New
Year ah we have a somewhat full room and
we're missing this is a memorial of the
fight nanny we're gonna miss her you
know can't believe it but you know we're
gonna miss her so we're leave the seat
open and I nearly died like nanny died
my baby is gonna take her place okay
we're gonna watch this baby grow up that
baby will talk more than the fight nanny
ever did and the strays everybody
tweeted the fight goes fight ghosts
joining us are one of our favorite
people on the planet returning champion
Cree Mathews everybody how are you
intercontinental that was the fun one
right that was the smaller guys we
really brought the heat right there like
god they're like chicks at the bar who
kind of girl fighting everybody right I
come in off the top rope yeah that's my
first move I love I always love when I
watch videos of tiny chicks fighting big
girls cuz fighting like like what in a
fight because it just lets you know that
they've gone so long without anybody
checking them on their [ __ ] that
they think they could just beat up
anybody like as men we learn very early
oh that dudes bigger than me he's gonna
[ __ ] me up right right
chances are yeah it's not a risk like
okay I'm gonna take a hundred times I
lose eighty nine of them yeah that's
enough for me to not win the alive yeah
using one of them is enough do you ever
see the video of the stripper in Vegas
who tried to fight the giant McDonald's
employee oh yeah and this stripper gets
[ __ ] because this girl like dude this
stripper is this gigantic McDonald's
girl that's a multi watch or two
everybody if you see that once easy it's
almost a snuff film
titties pop out chicks fighting but
cracks busts beating yeah it's
everything you ever want
right it's every rock but this stripper
is getting a beat-down from every what
person who's ever [ __ ] this big chick
up she's taking it out on it's like that
moment fight club or it's like I just
wanted to destroy something pretty you
know right yes okay this is my relief
yeah thank you victim time ah cream yadi
date you want push Instagram I'll be on
the Dark Side of the Moon actually with
the Chinese well the best instagrams you
will ever see in your [ __ ] life yeah
I post selectively nice fight media
that's why I say ass be - cuz sometimes
a good quality ass beating is makes your
day yeah worse than I am
thank God and they totally deserve these
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
get on up dog hey t-bohhh where are you
gonna be I will be that's not it I'm at
the comic store this weekend I mean it
comes with this week I will post those
dates today I know I'm there Saturday
but I don't know what other day daytime
there but I'm I'm sorry two times this
week and then I'll be a Hitler smart
house on Tuesday our house is the best
they take care of yeah it not a Hitler's
heart house the rooms are terrible very
very hot very hot very hot in those
rooms
ah and then I'll be at glory glory
hallelujah the best fried macaroni and
cheese it's called macaroni on their
knees Oh checking IDs at a Jamboree
every week that's the job suck it whoa
dude whoa you actually had some issues
what are you talking about
that's a big second on show all right
guys
January 15th is the comedy chaos double
feature
[Applause]
next Tuesday Tuesday Tuesday 7:00 p.m.
doors a p.m. show first show we have two
shows first show Eddie Bravo Joey Diaz
ah Joe Rogan Whitney Cummings Chris
Spencer with your master sandwich myself
second show ah
Brian kale and feel Dom Michael Rapaport
Eddie Bravo Bryan Callen and myself
sponsored by LA speed we'd dream donuts
and absolute app extract those shows
will hopefully salt they are at the
Comedy Store
hey there's no token black guy on the
second okay so it'll be two black guys
one I mean dude Michael Rapaport is
almost black Ami's trying oh yeah you
put him in the black slide on the flyer
yeah we're gonna get a new t-shirt guy
we need t-shirts I need you out there to
start drawing us some t-shirt ideas so
if you have an idea hit us up on Twitter
hit us up on Instagram if you got an
idea for a t-shirt we would love to work
a deal out to give t-shirts because this
show needs to start doing [ __ ]
t-shirts 2019 is going to be the
rebranding of punch-drunk sports we're
going to kick the [ __ ] into high gear
Johnny gets back ah
Chad sumachs gonna be joining us we're
working pretty tired of the fight
manager oh oh yeah I forgot so our this
is a remembrance of Chad sumac we're
gonna miss him too I mean
and Johnny I mean Johnny died yeah okay
can you just yes and this [ __ ] we just
moon that whole bit but the point is big
things are going we're gonna work hard I
know we said before websites coming up
and we're gonna start work a sketch
comic man about the t-shirts though he
does good he's on Instagram man get it
get it punch-drunk yo like
okay what's your logo look like is that
you just sucking LeBron James dick I
feel it with me onstage he just gave me
on stage doing like a 10-minute say
after my say this is a great this was a
great week of sports huh what a great
week of sports yeah this is a great time
this is probably here's an early October
right uh October and like March April my
two favorites right on now is mine oh
that's nice dude yeah he said Lisa
misses for sure for sure yeah they're I
mean dude t-shirts t-shirts t-shirts I
wanna start doing more and more and more
I think I'm gonna go with the guys doing
tinfoil hats t-shirts he's in town he's
our he's a great guy so I'll go grab he
makes them yeah he you know I well I
have a certain system I do I go on
Instagram and I'll find artists oh and
I'll be like hey can you do a t-shirt
for my podcast and they're like [ __ ]
yeah sometimes they want some cash give
them a little bit and for the artwork
yeah we're alright and this do print
some up yeah drop any prints him up and
he does it on demand joe Bartnik
introduced me to so you don't have to
order like a thousand yeah you want to
see some of the teachers that got go to
tinfoil hat podcast.com there's a whole
bunch of oh but i'll back to sports it's
a good time dude it's a good time it is
who is warming up and in the football
man the football is just juicy college
and pro like the championship game last
night you know what dude
my phone is acting up really bad like
really bad
I just forgot I I thought I had Clem
someone I just when they they're so
convinced that [ __ ] Alabama's gonna
win that's when like [ __ ] gets a little
weird when your life Hayes Alabama gonna
is gonna have I think a more deadly
Alabama is one with one loss Alabama
that's like a check a wounded dog yeah
they're like okay we could lose this
let's focus but when they steamrolled
everybody I always think that's when
he's when Damon is a baller ball no
absolutely I had Clemson last night - I
had cricket at four losses 19 and Oh 26
it would still would have got me by them
I mean well I I just think we're looking
at a quarterback that is just climbing
to [ __ ] I mean that what's his name
Lawrence Lawrence I mean like dude that
guy ya know to [ __ ] play football or
win wars right he looks like a Spartan
he's 65 240 and can move and got a gun
he's got married in college bar he can
run like Rosberg he's like a mobile
Manning but he doesn't you be idea was
one play where he stepped up in the
pocket like it looks so professional
yeah oh the rush was coming around him
and he just stepped into the pocket and
I threw a dime down for you like dude
that's the [ __ ] and if air cubies can't
do this is out look how good he is like
Gulf spill shits his pants in moments
like what I'm [ __ ] 19 yeah
go deep yeah dude and he's like I think
about if like Andrew Luck you gone to a
blue chip likes program yeah Andrew Luck
I like USC like that's yeah it's a it's
it's in the pack but it's not a
historically amazing school way because
they can't get the athletes like that
because of [ __ ] this the GPA to get
in there yeah I'm saying you only get 30
they could get pretty much anybody to go
to here's the weird thing about Alabama
they never get the top quarterback
recruiter they get every other top
recruit of every sewer was tool was it
he wasn't number one in his class know
what the number one QB or the number one
player I think he was really I think he
was do you I can check that though
somebody could check that I think you
think - somebody could check that are
you on the phone doing something I'm
getting a call from luck getting I'm
waiting for post mating McDonough maybe
they'll have this in Canada New Zealand
vampire I just like dude I think the
NCAA's biggest problems gonna be we're
getting the same teams every time yeah I
don't think that's a problem though
they're the best team I know but I think
I think if they had had word of it
that wasn't would I see that wasn't a
great game that was a rout but it look
like a coronation on top I mean Nate
Notre Dame was undefeated they wax Notre
Dame yeah everyone's like Oh Notre Dame
shouldn't have been in this then AWACS
Taliban yeah but I never never ever ever
convinced on Notre Dame because they
don't ever have enough speed yeah when
he gets to the top top level you guys
thank you many white guys is that what
you're saying well no because actually
Clara hammer white guys didn't [ __ ]
Notre Dame will not it don't but they
exposed Alabama speed last night
you can see who was the clearly faster
team is my theory here's my theory that
Nick Saban is a better recruiter than he
is a coach and I'll tell you why because
Nick Saban is a lot like what's-his-face
John Calipari in basketball he can light
you up if he's got more talent but if
you match him on tell
I think they get out coach absolutely
which is why they both in my opinion
failed in the NFL in the NBA because
they had the same level of talent and
sometimes they had less time and they
got house no that's a great point and
it's funny that you brought that up
because that one receiver for Clemson
that had the big game you know at 150
yards that freshman yeah he's from
Alabama and he's like the second top
player from Alabama not to go to Alabama
oh yeah and he said the reason he didn't
go was because the position coaches have
been changing so much that he wasn't
sure who was gonna be his wide receiver
coach when he got there oh that's yeah
that's surprises success alright and
also a lot what you see it about the
coaching I mean yeah it's a great
program but this kid felt like you know
I'm not confident on the coaching I'm
well I mean like like Saban went through
those two offensive coordinator in the
same year alright yeah well what's his
face that - yeah kiffin and then
sarkeesian all right you guys [ __ ]
hate falling from grace I don't even
know you're talking about it doesn't
work for a Falcons huh
okay but no it's crazy that it's for
kids at that level that's an important
thing like he's choosing between Clemson
and Alabama and the deciding factor is
who's my wide receiver coach yeah man
like well I mean when you have your
choice of everybody right like you know
you're crossing all the box Aliyah and
you could [ __ ] everybody but you're like
you're allowed to get picky on what kind
of feat you want on a driver who gets me
to the pros the fastest at my position
that's what you're concerned the most
prepare you think these kids go to the
ED - college football and pick like
where can I win a national championship
some do one pro bono the top ones -
though I feel like it's a combination
especially for football cuz you can't do
a one and done so you're gonna be at
that pleasure for at least 400 days
maybe three I think it's three it's off
right right right so you're gonna be
there I mean I think for basketball
that's different
they're gonna be on the
campus for like six months an hour and a
half right so they don't give a [ __ ] but
I think for football it's a combination
of getting ready for the pros and
winning you're me because again back to
last night's game their running back
from Alabama to backup running back that
was from the bay yeah but he's a
sophomore and he was a number one player
in his class and he can't like he can't
get on the field they were saying
Alabama was gonna give him a lot more
run yesterday cuz they knew he was home
and he was pissed you know I mean right
right it's like that would never happen
in basketball right you're the number
one player you're going somewhere where
they're gonna start you right away and
there's gonna be that man for those six
weeks that you're on campus my opinion
is is like you know really one last
night outside Clemson the rest of the
SEC become because why the gabilan
Alabama is that what this this SEC which
was you remember what during Cam
Newton's days like they were ready to
just jump the whole rasa college
football and just have the SEC playing
right and what happened is that that
Alabama became so dominant that the
people who would normally be spread out
amongst all the teams all just start
going Alabama
they're like if it's a little bit of
what you're saying a little bit of what
you're saying it's the surest way to get
to an nth or turn championship and the
surest way to get the FL so all these
teams have fallen off a little bit
Florida which LLS you they used to fight
for championships because it was you had
all these great coaches not just one guy
right so now it's like when you when you
lose clothes it doesn't it when you get
shellacked yeah these kids like yeah
we're not going there yeah so I think
it's good for Basque I'd the whole sport
for Nick Saban to get [ __ ] you know
taking out like that no absolutely and I
mean now like Clemson is turning into
that team cuz they'll be back everything
is coming back that Cuba and it lost
fresh years right semis last year they
lose to our oh no no no they beat
Alabama and champ ship last year - no no
Alabama won last year I think George
yeah Alabama beat Georgia in the Georgia
so call ant you know what else is gonna
be interesting
Texas is coming back you know they got
the coach finally they beat Georgia
Georgia was talking mad [ __ ]
nah and then they got house or they
didn't get house but they got beat that
was my favorite moment of the playoffs
by the way when the bowl tried to go
after the little dog that was hilarious
you like dogs like what's up balls like
[ __ ] what is this the rules of this [ __ ]
right the bull was trying to knock
people down and everything I don't want
to get onto a tangent with this but it
does it is stupid that in this modern
day era we have these prisoner animals
that have one job to come out at the
start of a game yeah but dude what are
the options for especially the ball -
either that or be a Big Mac that Bulls
cool right did some [ __ ] weirdo
stroke me off once in a while I'm good
to go
now but those mascots have been around
for like hundreds of years like you tell
Georgia they're not gonna be able to
bring the board dog Dave bring your dog
out run around let me take a [ __ ] on
[ __ ] you know they're like a buffalo
by Colorado they run that Buffalo out
sweep it by and they hit some lady and
they get all mad it's like Hawk yeah
that's all burn that does it yeah all
burns fall now oh yeah they have me it's
it really for college football it comes
down to recruiting man you know saying
like because again like with Nick
statement even if you don't coach these
kids you're gonna get to the
championship game like the coaching
comes in and the difference between you
winning it all or not but the top four
or five teams is pretty much recruiting
like right same thing with Georgia they
got two three NFL running backs on the
squad every year like they got three in
a few army boys there's so Knievel's are
just good at positions a quarterback
from Michigan offensive line from you
know running backs for Georgia fill of
God Damon put these receivers that
clemson has oh you didn't say what you
want about his quarterback a great game
370 yards and three touchdowns whatever
you do they were making unbelievable
catchable you know they are advice shoe
I love the shooting guards of the NFL
absolutely 65 220 with a 40 inch
vertical that was that one-handed cat
know that was there it's like almost
like the [ __ ] it was a kid Africa
Durham Alabama that's the freshman from
Alabama that decided to go to air
because of the receiver coach well you
could see why yeah he was Jos biggest
fool
Alabama pumps out receivers to don't get
that wrong yeah Jones
maricon Laurie Cooper not ridley right
but clemson to dog that's just in the
last five six years
clemson to toe i think their receivers
are higher level new popkins DeAndre
Hopkins oh yeah Sammy Watkins okay well
he's a little bit
the danger doing Garnett without even
trying to do it right now oh yeah do
from the Chargers and then these dudes
they got now just like and they got they
come they put out big receipts I just
say they're all poor - they're all
[ __ ] big balls B yeah I mean that
took that deep touchdown
well it wasn't supposed to be it was
like a little skinny route right that he
took like 80 yards or whatever he was
gone but the time he caught it he was it
was like no one's carolyn's catching her
Alabama's supposed to be fast like their
secondary is supposed to be good here's
the thing about the SEC and everybody
can go off when I say it every time the
SEC either plays SEC teams or junk teams
or no bar no cuz they feel like the SEC
so tough right right we're gonna get art
strip the schedule playing each other
Ronnie to schedule you right but that
makes it very hard to actually see what
you're up against you know what I'm
saying like it's like Barry and that's
the whole thing with these with these
four teams go to eight and they keep
acting like they give a [ __ ] about
education that is the most hilarious
thing in the [ __ ] world know you
don't give a [ __ ] about these students
or the student body this thing is making
you so much money but they know if they
expand it too
teams you're gonna start letting other
conferences in and that's gonna get
people a little more hope here you have
it unlocked I mean look how many teams
repeat every year it's these blue chip
programs like yeah dude now we're all in
because really go near the fire going to
the championship game is great you just
gotta make the playoffs and then
everybody at the administration's happy
that it is what it is
no they get pay everybody's arguing that
that a team like Notre Dame I was
looking this up cuz you're pointing like
they only play those teams and everybody
else is garbage and everybody argues
Notre Dame is not in a conference so
therefore they don't play anybody they
do play hard line listen to the other
who they and they were undefeated
Michigan they opened with Michigan horn
three at the time open September 1st in
Michigan then they play probably one of
the greatest colleges in all of the
world Ball State University through a
head banger yeah yeah take it easy I the
best three years of my life for my life
was my sophomore year gives a [ __ ] Wake
Forest where Stanford Vanderbilt still
SEC schools you just said Stanford
they're not a blue tip program all these
schools are good
Virginia Stanford is a good team
northwestern was ranked northwestern
Florida State Syracuse at USC Florida
State's the first one 98 were Michigan
was good no yeah right after Michigan
after missing see I disagree Stanford is
a top 20 but that's not a record we used
you just made the point before we
started not the bone chip [ __ ]
programs but a Bama and by the way
before saving got the Bama they were
[ __ ] bottoming out they but they have
always been a blue chip right well that
we let's see right now they're going
through their vamos it's Barry Marwan
has [ __ ] this up Pat Haden to don't get
it twisted the black-white Shattuck
right but like Lynn Swann had a pro at
this rate we're like let's just
swanny you see that cat she did that
time you know for the one pass Terry
Bradshaw actually Rio C is bad when
nepotism works for lynn swann because
that's how the business is none of these
do to qualify very like his weren't hire
and he [ __ ] it up but pat ray back
this guy hayden it was the same thing he
had no resume either he was the QB and
he wasn't even as good as Lynn no I'm
giving that no garbage with the Rams at
least miss mom wasn't winning some Super
Bowl I'm telling you man if this guy
Kingsbury another fight not even gonna
get the job he's gonna get it in a fair
job before he coaches one yeah which is
a yeah now that's ridiculous I just
think it's like Phil I know he put
Patrick model like everybody like
whoever work with Patrick my home is
getting [ __ ] something right now and
that's their whole thing the guy that us
see the Lewis II should be like let's
eat our [ __ ] let's eat this millions
we're gonna eat this we we shouldn't
gave him a [ __ ] contract extension
whatever the coaches name is he's [ __ ]
oh oh the coats now yeah what does the
name the coach yeah us code yeah but I
Johnny right now
USC food ID with Candace I know I you
see football coach ah buh buh buh me box
anyways I know people at home are
yelling it right now I heard them talk
about all right oh my God he's so and so
yeah they got Mike bleach from [ __ ]
Washington State that's what he's the
guy we basically learned where Kyle
kingsbere learned is uh he's a master
Duke it Kliff Kingsbury
learned his [ __ ] how to yeah yeah
that's true but again we had this we
talked about it I don't think he's right
he's a big market coach never had one
here Texas Tech Washington whatever I
mean they're both big conference no but
I'm saying the cities that I think la is
you know saying coach and s CEO that's
almost a pro job before we got these
thirteen beauty of it is just like
you're the fifth
most important like now now but it's you
have two NFL teams a baseball team and a
basketball team not including my team
that gets way more [ __ ] but SC still
holds a lot of clout in this video and
for football and when the wouldn't when
they're bad shellay oh by far enough
three years ago they were like the NFL
team like still to this day when people
say before the rams got here they've
only been they were good but still at
the Coliseum during Ram games when they
say that chain whose house some people
will say this is SC's how people say
that yo and I'm like this is not SC's
[ __ ] house it is though but that's
why I'm said that's how some people
people do think some people are renting
so a renters so in that case you do have
to have a high profile head coach like
it can't be oh no my telephone where is
ringing and now my call came through the
call I've been waiting for yeah weird
like Frankenstein Canadian now it
happened I have to go I don't know what
is why I couldn't be on air last night
watching Jimmy Schubert do magic for
black people or for Canadians no I don't
know Canadians are scared of magic like
black and that's no black people just
don't [ __ ] with magic cuz it's like come
on YouTube videos
what were you two V Oh baby people
performing magic to black people what it
is hilarious I'm sure every time the
trick it's everyone just runs like they
just saw a widget like witchcraft
because that's what I did to shoot I
didn't run but I'm I'm am out of here
yeah I walked off he's like no no come
back that's your thing dude you get into
black magic God do black people don't
for us are with like come on maybe one
black magician isn't right right that's
like your family a bad thing you know
how you get if you just
is anybody listening you're you're you
should go into [ __ ] magic do you know
what you know likes magic right [ __ ]
white [ __ ] love man see we can get
white [ __ ] without man yeah I know
but you're black we're just imagine more
same God that you're a if you're a but
if you're black and you're like hey I'm
gonna tell you family I'm gay and
they're like well we love you however
you are whatever you're like I'm doing
that they just jump out the window like
it's like that or out that or I'm now
taking up ice skating so would you
rather you're your son be a figure
skater or your daughter do porn oh damn
wait that's a I mean you of course
you're gonna say my son doing figure
skating because you don't want your
daughter doing porn but you not you're
saying he'll be at those figure skating
matches like either way your kids taking
a lot of dick hey but tell him about the
trick though the trick oh I don't [ __ ]
with magic but the trick was kind of
impressive
and by the way Jimmy sherbert will be
here next week
promoting his new album and I told him
bring some magic tricks so he's gonna we
should never a roomful of black people
not but lock the door so they can't run
anywhere so he had everybody pick a card
and he's like here's your card and
here's your card and and and a your
creamed card is gone so he fans out all
the cars in like you could totally gone
right and we looked at every car D like
yeah yeah yeah it was a jack of spades
right
yeah when before that there were more
levels to this trick like before he got
to this point he had made some cards
which you know this was supposed to be
this car but it turned out to be this
card and then you know here's your car
yeah you know some [ __ ] you kind of had
before and I was like okay yeah that's
cool but then he got to the part that
that Tebow is talking about this that's
that's what made it crazy was this trick
had like six or seven different there's
levels yes that's what I told our that
okay the levels made it even made it in
mine do you remember
I mean we were talking about it on the
on the right over he may be that he was
leaving reading into his car when I can
you do one trip before you leave so he
like what's even really prepared as far
as we knew right it wasn't like he was
like hey you guys want to see a trick
he was kidding to his car right which
maybe that's part of his trick to trick
you and asking them okay now I may be
but again yeah right but yeah so then
his card was a jack of spades and then
it's gone and he first he fans on the
deck out the car was in the debt I mean
he he said okay then he put the card the
deck back together then then went
through each card
individually and told that the car
wasn't in there so he goes well what if
I told you puts his hand in his [ __ ] dad
and he pulls out like the empty case of
the car okay what if how to get into
your [ __ ] thing no he said what if I
told you I folded it up and put it in
the car case he said what if I told you
that and then that would have been right
that would have been crazy but that's
not what he did a knife comes out of the
card case wait no yes oh no no he so he
tells me to hold my hand like this and
he's gonna empty my card that he was
supposed to have folded into my hand so
I'm holding my hand and I know it's not
gonna be my card I'm just like what the
[ __ ] is he gonna drop in my hand my
car's gonna be something nasty you know
Cobra I don't know but I knew it wasn't
gonna be my car dookey right that's the
kind of [ __ ] I was sent by blacks ain't
met exactly as they try to make so he
[ __ ] dirt the car case like this in
which place a knife drops out oh [ __ ] a
handy [ __ ] knife you want there with
all the different compartments Oh like a
Swiss Miss yeah
yeah so then exactly nice so we're
dinner [ __ ] aligned what does the line
come from is there a guy that's why
opens this up and pulls a [ __ ] uncut
lime out of his thing he dropped a knife
in my hand and pulls a line all around
where opens it and the card is folded up
in the line mark the jack of spades is
in the line this guy all the sudden this
guy I'm [ __ ] uncut he fertile on Jesse
Owens breaks 100-yard dash yeah Marty
uncut line first he drops a knife in my
hand out the thing then he pulls a under
the lime is solid yeah he uses a knife
to cut the lime open and in the uncut
line I rolled like a joint hold it in
there is the card the jack of spades
yeah this [ __ ] unfolds the card
and keeps it you don't say anything she
would just walks off yo Mike drop that
[ __ ] yeah do I mean dude
the line was uncut like if the line had
you know yeah if it was open already you
could be like okay yeah yeah but he had
to [ __ ] cut it open right in front of
us even if it was jammed in there and
like oh how did he get you to get to
[ __ ] that card when three other
people got to pick a card
it was crazy do you know it what nah
right great I ain't [ __ ] with that
[ __ ] that's exactly not just that was
gonna be my next sentence and that's why
I don't [ __ ] with man what's the word
what's the fear there there's no fear
come on man what was going on there yo
like I'm yummy I don't even want you to
explain to me what just happened but I
don't we you know I'll explain to you
what happened dude you got Jimmy
Cooper's guy going use some of that
magic at that DSi bet the aside for all
still go use that you want got that
magic go use that magic make that magic
money dude
bat deicide for all your bet needs I use
the promo code punch 25 that's right and
you will get 25 dollars betting cash and
anything up to five dollars at which you
deposit they will match that now we got
big announcement we're excited to
announce punch-drunk
and bet the asite will be having a Super
Ball party live at the Sycamore tavern
there will be that you'll be able to
watch the game and you're gonna be able
to go upstairs and watch some stand-up
comedy from your favorite comedians
that'll be the day of the Super Bowl is
that our Super Bowl party cuz that's
copyrighted it will be our Super Ball
party right are you gonna be in town of
it I was just gonna say if the Rams
aren't in the Super Bowl
are you gonna go to the game if you can
oh no we're not to the game but then
well maybe definitely to Atlanta if the
Rams and chargers around for ball we
will be cancelling our suit right if the
rather in the Super Bowl I'm going to
Atlanta and we'll see about getting into
the game but if not I'm [ __ ] with
y'all yeah come down stand up see cream
and we're gonna have magic on stage why
cream does stand up the whole time then
they won't just [ __ ] with them just
[ __ ] with the bell we really should
have you back
Oh to see that trick bring all of your
friends you know what I mean when I say
there will be lack of door we're gonna
do some parlays here let's get into
these let's get into these games next
week because I honestly I'll tell you
what I'll tell you what I will bet on a
bet DSi
on these four games because this is a
perfect time of year for a parlay
because it's for NFL games and that's it
bro all the money is on the line I would
highly recommend taking all of your
money I feel like this is putting on a
on a parlay just on the NFL Vegas is
real sharp around these times so when it
is only for games their focus is
laser-like they usually have them to the
point you wonder if
it's rigged no they have a really big
electric bill and as a reason I was like
hey by the way my father every day would
be Sam if I could just get the electric
bill for Vegas for one day we'd be set
for the rest of my life I'm like okay
dad I don't know what the lines are here
I'm trying to look them up but Michael
they're all relatively close I know the
NFC is crazy
Saints are favored by a trams are
favored by seven I think the Patriots
are favored about four and a half I
think and these are favored about five
and a half oh yeah all a touchdown or
less right around there that DSi right
now okay let's go through some of these
games and we'll get your guys's feel on
that
let's do why is this only got this game
on you [ __ ]
I'm a boy okay indie appleís Colts at
Kansas City Chiefs ah the Colts are plus
three see that's what I mean that's
close
I mean I'd take the Chiefs that all day
really three days I think Andrew Luck
has a better defense I think he is a
better defense and he's cooking with gas
right now III would like for the Colts
to him and I think cheese went for three
at Kansas City is a very tough place to
play this late in the season that's
that's a very hostile Stadium I'll take
the cheese that where are you sure that
that's what best dsi have you sure
that's not the first half bet cuz oh my
[ __ ] the girls are getting five and a
half spread dude
all right I don't know but I would I'd
be just a first half bet mine the cheat
the Colts are getting five and a half
points I mean five and a half on that I
probably will go coach at five and a
half yeah I'm rolling
cuz I'll buy say if it's only a three
point line that shows you who they think
is gonna win that game cuz you get three
points just for being a whirl winner in
the backfield
ever since my dream you know not me that
was a different Kareem are you sure
that's why I came home to tell people I
did not beat kick different black cream
right
I think Kareem hunt isn't afraid of
magic on this one
[Laughter]
exactly
this one has Kansas City four and a half
okay that's close so I mean I I really
do think the Colts are gonna win this
one so I think we forgot 4:30 was no I
mean like dude we didn't think he was
gonna come back while somehow he did cuz
he's a machine and he is what we thought
he was one of those like all-time great
right like similar to pay him a knee and
I feel like your luck to me he's more
proven than mahomes and again played 16
games exactly his life right this is his
first playoff exactly nah he wasn't
first you beat Alex Smith he was he was
on the team but Alex Smith was running
the show look it's proven yo and again
that line I'm telling you you that line
gives it away cuz you get three points
for being at home whatever good so they
think the Chiefs are only really a one
and a half point favorite like you see
an NFC they're giving eight and seven
you know saying the Chiefs only gave him
four and a half Vegas is not stupid yo
like you said those light bills gotta
get paid yeah I'm a guy I ever hope
sweating that well ya know
alright I'm wrong and I'm definitely I'm
loving the points but I think the call I
would love for the Colts to be now
here's an intro this one la Chargers
which still sounds weird I know to the
new New England Bob Chargers are getting
four and a half I'm taking the Chargers
I know that sounds crazy doesn't not at
all I'm a Raiders fan and I don't know
why but I'm rooting for [ __ ] you know
why cuz it a tuck rule yeah why me I
actually want Phillip Rivers to do what
I don't like to be angling [ __ ]
cuz this man that's in your subconscious
mama I'm a grown man who appreciates a
man who puts in the work who's put in
the work and like he's getting that age
where it's like how many more times does
he have this chance
plus he came in his wife a lot yeah
that's got a lot of kids
and like a lot of them uh girls like a
t-shirt gun Tiana Hannah
Tiana went to the Ravens Chargers game
and somebody had a sign that said
Phillip Rivers has more kids than the
Ravens have wins they're like you know
he's still commutes to San Diego he
still lives yeah with all that money
probably can't afford I mean like he
know he commutes and on the ride he's
watching film you know I'm saying he
gets driven back and forth every day why
he gets such a bad rap
he does a lot of people don't like that
guy and I like I don't know why a lot of
[ __ ] oh and some people wrote it out on
Iverson yeah but I like [ __ ] talkers oh
I love it
like Joel embiid I love that he [ __ ]
is wrecking people's feet in their faces
I love that [ __ ] because that's how I
was when I play I I can appreciate that
too I never knew people didn't like for
the rivers I root for them if I had to
have a B team it will be the Chargers
you know even from the San Diego day
it's like I'm not a fan yeah I'm a Rams
fan ball on that wagon this year but I
want the Rams Chargers Super Bowl and I
felt puts a [ __ ] gun in their mouth
every owner puts off a [ __ ] gun in
their mouth see I think are you [ __ ]
me they've been trying to bury this
charges situation forever there's a
homeless NFL team their whole yard
they have no no held their body don't
acknowledge no there never is gonna be
their home there's a kid that the NFL
doesn't acknowledge they're the one not
no no because they be the way you those
killed themselves if they beaten the
England and if it Rams and charters
Super Bowl they're like you don't think
they'll have a home then if the Chargers
make it do y'all forget two years ago
the rounds are going for intend this
before in 12 this wasn't their home for
two people were like [ __ ] the race I
absolutely don't if it's Chargers Rams
Super Bowl I think next year there's the
exact same amount of Chargers fans and
the exact same amount of RAM
I know the RAM fans the right answer
Chargers have a Raiders problem they
have a real Raiders problem in town
they're later later wins will be like
okay I lose the Rams because they're not
they have seen they're not in our
division Chargers charger like I'm
rooting for Phillip Rivers the person
not the team right
[ __ ] the Chargers okay he's Eurasian be
in Vegas the charger should be in Vegas
Raiders should be here but he goes just
like everything we're seen in television
egos our [ __ ] overriding common sense
yeah but I know I feel you on that and
the car that does make a lot of sense
the charges in Vegas the Raiders here
everyone would have been a lot happier
but if the chart I mean even if the
Chargers beat New England you know like
LA loves a winner like the Rams didn't
have fans in LA two years ago I was
going to the games people dressed as
seats this season him said this season
it turned into a real oh hey I went took
him like you know once again this United
a night and day there's still were a lot
of Viking fans at the game oh no they
took it over the most the no actually
Green Bay Green Bay it was like a Green
Bay home game they were tile gating
hours before out front the Vikings were
second the Eagles were third that still
happens but those teams travel like you
know saying yeah there's a lot of people
out here that live here yeah and then
it's what the [ __ ] is going on in
Minnesota in November like you want to
come to LA you plan your vacation for
the year you know they were thinking
about for a brief second move making it
an outdoor stadium with no roof
oh I'm like you guys that there are
idiots no they they have that Minnesota
soda it's like oh we want to have a
Vantage when you play here
oh no play inside right here's the
reason we built roofs and we have
buildings and we have walls I drink that
[ __ ] off I'm not against that though
they used to have that back up in an
area like there's something to be said
about being at in the social field when
it's like Minnesota got some classic
snow games like where they were it was
frozen in a some playoff game
gross yeah I don't want that either but
a back to this Ram [ __ ] though you're
saying how it changed before we get into
that well because we had discussed Rams
let's get into Dallas Rams right now
seven and a Rams are giving up some of
the altar charges and we like it yeah
okay okay so right now Dallas Wembley
you have who do you have on Kansas
Indianapolis I got the coat I have the
coal-tar you have the Colts I want the
Colts but I think the jeez okay but and
then we all three Chargers over New
England
ah next one is the LA Rams vs Dallas
Rams for sure and what's the spread the
spread is seven yeah I'll take rims on
it I'll take Rams by the way Rams won by
about 10 this isn't reality matchup the
other two teams are gonna give him
[ __ ] trouble
or well I think Seattle was probably the
best matchup but this was a close second
I mean we had lost to Philly and the
Bears on Philly and New Orleans I mean
the next round is gonna be real hard oh
and the Bears haven't played the Bears
we would have played what you guys
thoughts on that game we could have
played one of them oh I had Philly on
there I knew I knew they were gonna win
I thought the Bears gonna win I swear
dude when the kick was going on I text
my boy I have the text I was like he's
going to miss this I knew he was gonna
miss it but then then when he made the
one where they called the timeout
oh my if it guaranteed now there's no
way he makes the second one because that
dude that [ __ ] really works when they
ice the kicker and he makes the one on
the ice you feel that you got to take
that free kick how would he take the win
I wouldn't take it I would take it I was
not even taken how it's blow I would not
have taken it I've never seen a kicker
make the second one the pressure I've
seen it have you after that blows up in
your face yeah I've seen it worse you to
miss the freebie and then make it is
whenever they make the free one they
knew I was standing before the time I
will play Harrison clay Helton oh that's
how it is right
SC's codes oh but before the ice I was
texting my brother I am not even worried
he's
not gonna make this and then he made
them the the Mulligan I like ha
the kiss of death and then short enough
for it to hit the upright the crossbow
who I feel that even made it worse I
wish you two just blew off just blow to
the left it wouldn't even be like it I
here's what I feel bad if I might one of
my buddy I grew up with longtime best
friend Chris Albert he's I'm his son is
I like a fourteen inch and they got
season tickets to the Bears mmm and so
this was his first ever playoff game
ever paint my buddy chase and I'm like I
wanted to like text and be like amen
sorry little buddy we've done like hey
man little scoop of [ __ ] sandwich man
for life being a Bears fan your life now
hopefully not you know hopefully not my
mom we do we think that Dallas can pull
anything off I mean anything's possible
I guess but it's girly gonna be ready oh
hell yeah it's girly gay if you a girly
man is he a girly man which you're
thinking attack hit hold hit hold okay
I mean girly sounds like getting the
cross-dressers am i right yeah I guess
so but I'm gonna say no he's not you're
saying you hope ease we need the rumor
do where's the rumor [ __ ] guy rumor if
you're watching kollywood some leave and
confirm that girly ya know about this
Ram gay no that's what I was trying to
say about how la can turn seat on the
feel for this game or hitting for 10 G's
see the problem when the Rams and the
Chargers ticket for what - for this
Dallas game for the Dallas game for the
bo-best
no the cheapest is 300 and you're
sitting on the moon in the endzone
take vo love a queenly can't get a free
ticket when you're a hot blonde chair
you can't you can just have lowered our
standards no or work a little harder
right right she'll get right but few
level seats are hidden for 10 G's oh
yeah that's that's ultimately what's
gonna ruin markings gonna be $500 yeah
it's too much it's too bulky
oh by the way did you hear up cake
quickly went to the last game and she
went there with Jack Jr and Jack hit
this Mexican guy was selling uh parking
spots he asked him how much was parking
and they he's like 10 bucks in there
something I forget what they drove up
she came back around and cake oh no 20
bucks and caicos how much is parking
same guy 40 bucks
Wow and that's well I wonder where they
were Parkin ain't no parking around
there that's some [ __ ] dude hey the
lowest parking we see is 80 and then
when you get close to stay 100 yeah [ __ ]
the ramp here we park on the other side
of SCS amazing plane and I'll jump out
I'll parachute we found a critic both
[ __ ] box I said that'll be cheaper
than paying for parking service instead
of Park you know that game is gonna be
great I can't even of course I'm going
with the ran man are you going because
oh yeah shotgun so what I gotta tell you
exactly what ours is 110 so you got and
to tick are 110 224 your two tickets and
our tickets for 110 or 74,000 see and
they wonder why every game in LA thought
about selling my [ __ ] yeah that would
pay for the whole [ __ ] season do you
sell them and guess where you can sell
seek it go to see use the promo code
what is wrong
punch drunk and dude all the time
Garnett got us tickets and he went by
himself but he did get us tickets on see
geek dude uh it's really I dude I get
all my sporting events whether it's
boxing MMA everything I you see geek
it's the most easy and dude you know
what now I got this up I go see more
sports because it's just so easy grab
tickets real quick especially as a
clipper fan they're doing great and
nobody gives a [ __ ] we were looking up
tickets today you can play if you get
there early enough you can get in yeah I
believe that we're good team anyway yeah
so I mean go use it the best part about
SeatGeek is that they are there they let
you know what are the good values or the
ship values and the word is the word
they'll pay 150 to park somewhere and
then find out that your tickets are fake
or oh yeah you get to your seat
somebody's sitting there and they got a
ticket to seeing MMA they got great mm
if I wasn't gonna be in are in Edmonton
at the end of the month
hey guys guess what's coming to the
Pantages Theatre Katz guess so you can
get to your publication that's really
coming yeah dude they got Flyers our
boys go that that was remember what we
were young dude down like the big thing
it was like in my neighborhood was
excited about cats the black version
with a zine said I probably do some [ __ ]
like that see now we're back now that
was the way as the will whatever Debbie
Allen was he actually kind of caught on
yo so go grab your tickets go see cats
go bye hey if you're in LA
buy a ticket I'll go somewhere with you
that's cash bar ticket to cats and rats
that's a garnet didn't you didn't show
up with some people did he win she
always wins don't afraid I'm gonna show
you something in a few that might blow
your mind magic some more man no but
some crazy
[ __ ] let's do the final game okay yeah
so uh grab your tickets I mean dude you
gotta grab your playoff tickets now when
hot blonde chicks can't get tickets for
free if you know it's a hot ticket in
this town ah so thank you to our friends
there they're gonna ride with us for the
next year SeatGeek
thank you very much ah Philadelphia
versus New Orleans can the magic happen
again can fools pull out the magic I'm
rolling with it
I'm rolling you know I'm saying I'm
taking the points it's like eight points
right yeah I'm taking the point and I'm
putting something on Philly straight win
yo I guess something going on with falls
man I don't ever doubt the champion in
any sport until they lose riot and this
is still you organs even though they
were winning they were really rocky
towards the end yeah and and this is the
playoffs you know like he'll saying it's
something about having that playoff
experience you know I mean I mean the
Saints have playoff experience as well
from the coach and the QB but we're
talking about the Super Bowl
championship last year and in this nick
foles story like you can't really write
to you if you're if he wins it again
what do you do if you're the Eagles you
have Carson Wentz who's having problems
staying healthy and every time you
replace him this fool Super Bowl wins it
and then you guys start talking about
where is Falls in history how many guys
have won two Super Bowls if somehow they
pull this off right no not many I mean I
feel like he has at least earned a
starting job like what I mean when it's
played like seven games right yeah they
weren't that great like two and five
right exactly they're like six of one
but here's what we're learning with
these these even though medicine and
Health has gotten so bad that these guys
get on quicker mentally I think the
injury lasts longer mentally than it is
physically we're seeing it all the time
we talked about last time with you know
I don't think you're gonna see the real
boogie cousins until this time next year
right what's the thing with with wins I
think the knee
injury took away one of his strength was
which was running and then that fourth
him to get hurt other they should have
sat him all year
he should have Andrew Luck them yeah I
mean either way I feel like foals fits
better with this team yes I'm not saying
we're told it's a better QB but he fits
better with what Philly has like wins
and Ernst our boys like they're so tight
then that's really only who wince looks
for you know saying right right
Ernst was breaking the tight-end record
yeah we went in there sure was falls
uses everybody like else on Jeff
Jeffries right he became a monster under
fold like once wasn't really using him
like that you know a huge Super Bowl I
mean even this season this season he
came on when foals
took over he gets frozen falls like he
doesn't look at just who oh that's my
boy I'm only looking for my boy you know
saying like Winston Earth's have that
combination but that doesn't help them
win football right well I mean what the
Eagles have is that they beat the best
defense in that conference they beat
they went in there on their field
outdoors beat them so the biggest
question is can the Eagles defense do
anything to stop the Saints offense I
think I think it's gonna be more the
Eagles offense you know say I think
they're gonna control like I do I take
the over this game I think it's gonna be
a high-scoring game is that playing the
Eagles I think that place is Center I
think so too and that's why I don't I
don't I think the Eagles are gonna try
to limit the possessions you know I'm
saying I don't think they're gonna try
to run up and down the field with the
Saints like I feel like the best way to
beat the Saints just keep the ball other
exactly and I feel like foals can do
that you know saying he doesn't turn the
ball over like I don't know man
I didn't say I got the Saints in this
one I'm rolling I'm own Saints I'm
rolling with the e you didn't wanna go
in again so bad dude even at eight I
still go saves
yeah I'm rolling with the eagle I mean
I'm definitely taking the points don't
get me wrong I'm covering my ass say
your pick straight wins so hard dude
it's so hard
so I think here we go I'm gonna go
giman SAMSHA please thanks yes I pick is
the same no you not agreed on everything
but that one and I think you and I
agreed on everything but Kansas City so
we'll see
so we all have also though if the Eagles
win the NFC Championship game will be in
LA I will really how much do you think
those team and those are by the way if
the Eagles win the NFC Championship game
is in the Coliseum on the 20th of if the
Saints win is in New Orleans yeah that's
right I think the I think the Rams have
to be like okay we're going to see these
people pretty sexy and either way we
lost to the Eagles to now Eagles beat
with foals that's what I'm saying the
Eagles beat us and the Saints beat us so
whoever it is is gonna be a team that
has already beaten this but I was much
rather have it in the Coliseum to that
Colts Colts where I was taking would be
20 G's amazing Colton that's Anil Colts
win Chargers win Colts win Chargers win
that game is in a soccer stadium right
the AFC Championship game would be in LA
how would that be in a 20,000 seater
oh those tickets cost oh I can't even
imagine
cuz the charger seats are already three
times thrice oh yeah nobody's at the
game well cuz they only have 20,000 well
these [ __ ] big are we gotta make
our blood don't get it just like yeah
like everybody outside la comes in like
it's a life they'll pay whatever that's
gonna go we won't pay whatever you know
why chosen option for Madden nosebleed
there no that's what I'm saying we know
it you're absolutely right it's like one
level there's only one left
oh my god dude this week Blake Griffin
comes back to the Clippers mmm oh that's
a good I might have to go to that game
I'll see keep that [ __ ] to the end of
[ __ ] time yeah Blake Griffin it is so
I was talking to a friend about that
like Blake Griffin I said to my friend
remember Blake Griffin yeah like he's my
hero
that's why that's my point
still having a good year but no State
Farm commercial nokia Comedy Central
show no roast battle no branding ruin
Lob City that [ __ ]
I love them [ __ ] Neal Brennan I love you
you're [ __ ] sketchy Oh ruined my
dreams okay yeah I mean it's just when
la is this something about planning and
that's when when she started dating that
Jenner [ __ ] Jerry Wes was like not
today not never Satan get out of here
and they shipped him there and that's
why he's having a great season the
problem with the pistol it had great
seasons here but dude it was started
like dude getting injured all the time
you know why cuz he wasn't focused there
there's nothing else to do right but
they're still not that good I mean his
numbers are pretty similar you know the
problem is they they're he's one of
those guys who are on a team where they
have two stars and they can't beat
anybody who's got three stars that's the
problem dude I mean even the box you
could have an argument they have three
stars I mean Eric blood so when he's on
Kim ball
yeah half star he's a high I'm giving
him a half saw a to nap stars more than
two stars yes it is yeah early on the
pissing those two guys and it drops off
to goodbye Blake and Drummond yeah I
mean are they really stars I mean I feel
you Blake Griffin is a star dude there's
no doubt about it he's a star I guess if
I was I feel like that was more in the
Hollywood you know I said Hollywood made
him a star I watched him play
oh you but there I see ugly he was when
he got drafted he's hot he's
good-looking guy now I don't know dude
you're like this guy's weird-looking
freckles and [ __ ] look like something
out of like Archie comic Obie how does
[ __ ] know la la does that to people I
mean I had like like a celebrity
makeover I make another season similar
with Chris Paul yo like he was a star in
LA you know saying is he a star yeah cuz
he's hurt dude
oh he was hurt here he was hurt but
still doing commercials my all-star
trade you a for sensibly magic trade are
you ready for the magic trade yes that's
here hey don't use the M word doesn't
you know what
[Laughter]
lock the doors
let's call this episode black magic show
young that's what you call um Chris Paul
should go to the sun's something about
that that city that [ __ ] area they
heal up but they got the drugs you know
they got their little no seriously like
they did Grant Hill they did a Shaq Shaq
Kurt Worley oh yeah Barkley to mash was
like remember he couldn't say healthy
Dallas we're not know seriously they
have a doctor down there that's doing
some some [ __ ] black man need a point
guard who you get know who dude at this
point Houston should just want to get
out from that contract and they played
better without him yeah dude
hey man mellow soon as they got hurt
they would go from zero to hero quick
Chris Paul would have enough shooters
around him and that's what he needs
boom boom boom oh but they gotta give up
some you know say Houston won what
Booker you know know that you know they
want that first thing the rights to Zion
yeah and I love ya know I haven't been
more excited about a college basketball
players at this much since probably when
Shaq was that LSU whoa fighting player
come out to come out since LeBron no but
I'm saying to come out into a draft
alright I won't say college I'm just
saying coming into the draft the most
exciting player since LeBron yeah and I
feel absolutely maybe knock the money on
and a Duke game is on
are you gonna walk in the day I would
just be on your [ __ ] oh yeah oh my
highest potential may not be the most
skilled at the moment but the highest
ceiling for
Charles Barkley as a shooting guard
he's Bill Antonio Gates he's way bigger
than Charles Barkley - he's way bigger
than anybody that size he's like LeBron
size
he's probably bigger than a bronze no
way he's six six right but look he's 285
yeah 19 right an explosive though you
know I mean I can jump out of the gym
like some of those dunks like that's why
that takes his ceiling to somewhere
where a lot of these kids can't read not
to say he's gonna follow him I would be
in the gym every day with a shooting
coach shooting threes if he gets that
game oh I'm not manageable jumper it
doesn't even have to be a three just
something that people have to respect
there's one thing I guarantee you is not
doing going to the Magic Castle yeah
yeah why should we give money because
that's a lie next you know it's all
magic shows no and then the
marketability you don't saying that oh
yeah that and the explosiveness names on
is something someone could write like
LeBron the one name Jordan because ions
come on the air if he brings anything on
the court Jews are gonna love the AIDS
are Jews and everybody into the major Oh
hilarious dude if he brings anything on
the court
those shoes are gonna go you know saying
some on the court so - where do you want
him to go because you know Cleveland's
just Chicago right Chicago any of these
[ __ ] teams cuz it's gonna be to
groom him for LA or I think your Lakers
are in deep deep trouble
I think this Anthony Davis thing is
pissing people off about how they're
like he's got like ESPN who's being
pissed off all these small market teams
and what does that mean well hey dawg
hey you're not going to be able to give
a [ __ ] if nobody wants
workman was pissed off about us getting
LeBron I'm sure they weren't happy about
no they that was a they're fine with
LeBron going because yeah because they
went on a nice four-year run the guy
owns a [ __ ] franchise and had to let
his employee run it okay
hey be like that sometime yeah so I'm
done yeah he doesn't [ __ ] mind it and
I think I talked to people really like
good let him go we overcome [ __ ] like
that people have hated on the Lakers
doing the [ __ ] we do for you but back in
the day they needed the Lakers be good
for the [ __ ] league they do ratings
are higher than they've ever been the
Lakers have LeBron yeah you're crazy bro
you don't think the NBA needs the Lakers
to be good they don't in any sport when
LA is good and they don't sport is
really on top it helps the cherry on top
it puts more money on everyone's hot
show that when the whole league is good
the league is better off no it's not
yeah the rating has spiked this year
because LeBron is it it is cherry
no one wants to go to Cleveland for the
finals no one wants to go to San Antonio
for the finals it's a style everyone
wants to come out in any sport in any I
hope logic if I was knew I was like okay
we're not gonna be able to turn this
around quick enough I must send this
dude somewhere do you think the NFL
needed LA to be good
no absolutely that's why they form here
yeah but why they say force-feed in two
teams it was ridiculous no the NFL
wanted that because they make more money
yeah you're not gonna be able to charge
10 G's for field seats anywhere else by
the way by the way anywhere else that
number isn't going to the team that is
that's third party people charging that
so the end that the Chargers aren't
getting the [ __ ] too early the Rams
aren't getting a tan grant that is some
really dumb following that's oh that
does have a butt dude but it's Bill
you're totally right no right now I was
gonna say but they still make more money
when the teams are in LA
just a market rocket the money they
charge their love calf these games but
let me be CLA is paying more than NBC
Cleveland for airtime you know saying
these commercials in LA during the games
you're getting more resident I
understand that they won the game but
I'm telling you dude that the arrest the
NBA they want to compete it's better for
the rest the NBA that sure is dumb as
[ __ ] okay okay I usually don't agree the
magic is how I reacted to that [ __ ]
shirt I ran in my try out the card and I
wanted to drive didn't notice what Laker
isn't on there Magic Johnson because
these are the last two you know if I had
everyone here to serve as a LeBron hater
I am NOT a LeBron hater at all but this
of like trying to force Anthony Davis to
the new words if I was New Orleans I
would move them somewhere else I would
go okay we're not gonna be able to turn
this thing who can we get the most from
and again if you're being logical the
Lakers are gonna offer you as much as
you're gonna get from anywhere else
because the package is gonna be of like
a Kuzma or Ingram one of those two a kcp
or Josh Hart one of those two possibly
Lonzo I like moving him possibly Alonso
I love but don't hate them in a deal
Frank Davis like the Lakers could
actually give New Orleans enough to
rebuild you know say if you get Lonzo
kcp and Ingram and JaVale McGee for
[ __ ] Anthony Davis you tell me that's
a lopsided trade for you're saying
they're gonna lose them anyway like well
the problem with a baby loss it hurt a
lot maybe Boston could give them which
is really the best package so they've
been taught some other [ __ ] it's similar
you know I mean but does Boston I mean
Boston probably would do that Boston
wants to deal but it's not like the
Lakers are just gonna you know sand
robbed them for Anthony Davis it's just
that y'all don't want the Lakers back
like we always are
I can understand that
everyone only listening to this on audio
right now Sam's face is see you so you
don't like magic but you made it smell
it disappears oh now I don't like magic
I like magic Johnson I don't like that
[ __ ] Jimmy Schumer did [ __ ] lie that
really is I swear to god it's a thing to
it I was laughing last night because I
want to you know you get caught in
YouTube holes where you're watching talk
now you porn YouTube but you know like
bully gets what's coming to a more
[ __ ] [ __ ] like that right pretty much
your whole instagram right right [ __ ]
but there is one that's like a rabbit
hole of people performing magic to black
people and it is it's baffling the white
people do you think there's because
racism in that I don't think so do you
know man you know black people we is
this certain [ __ ] quick that's where I'm
basketball I want to do NBA have you
heard this thing about this I don't know
if she's in high school or college where
this one girl in Alabama he's dunking no
she was playing she played for Team USA
and Team USA made a clerical error right
I'm going to look at this up this is why
people hate old white men this is why
because they [ __ ] like they paid hold on
got your awful [ __ ] I tried to put
you on it but we do so this is this
crazy-ass dumb this dumb situation is
why people hate old white men right well
this girl Mary Laurie Davenport she she
played for Team USA and Team USA sent
them a check
she-she also play colonize Rutgers
women's basketball shiny ah she played
on the day Center check for $157 they
said to everybody okay ah but she made
her ineligible yeah she she offered to
pay the money back and this [ __ ]
won't let her pay play her I think it's
her senior year in college
well the NCAA is the one that's not
letting her play right no it's one it's
in particular one guy why did she ever
cash do you have to have cash now buzzer
yeah but the other girls have to and
they returned the money and their state
said okay we're cool now
all the other girls are in college yeah
and it's from Alabama that's whack yeah
but why would they said no the [ __ ]
she's got anywheres he's going to
Rutgers yes he was on high school and
that makes her eligible for car oh my
god okay I mean Rutgers is a good female
basketball team and also if your I
school kid like you don't know any
different yeah teachable moments man and
these people [ __ ] completely blew it
and it's guys just like it's these
little ass [ __ ] who get these
[ __ ] these the power and they just
want to [ __ ] abuse the [ __ ] out of it
this girl did nothing wrong like if she
was taking money like oh hey do pay me
and I'll come play for you
that'd be different she literally got
st. Jack she's like okay yeah and
unfortunately mother wasn't smart enough
to go whoa I don't know if we could take
this check right we'll see and I was
just gonna say you brought the mother up
but I always blame the adults in this
situation man like the [ __ ] that
sent her to check should have known that
she was in high school his name is
Johnny Harden go [ __ ] yourself you got
his phone number you know what that
that's very similar to that incident
where they made that kid could have
dreadlocks for that wrestling match that
was terribly did you see that see that
the wrestling because it was a violation
of the co and again I'm like somebody
should have known this [ __ ] rule
before he showed up to the man
and I wasn't that first time he wrestled
with those either that's what I'm saying
he didn't grow those dreadlocks with
last man exactly no adult knew this rule
before he had to cut his hair on the
spot now the real trouble that is the
rule right no and the guy got fired for
enforcing the rule because he came off
as culturally insensitive let's face it
people made into a race thing no
absolutely and it's a rule because the
guy had had trouble before that racial
is right okay so that guy - that's not
the same guy yeah [ __ ] that guy the same
guy but I'm just like you know take the
race out of it man the adults in that
situation should have been able to
prevent that kid from being put in that
position he's a [ __ ] high school
listen to cut somebody's dreads in the
middle of a batch is so dumb desert-like
that's why why is it called common sense
it's not common at all yo that's my
point that should be called
enlightenment now stop calling Kong's
you are enlightened
okay do you gonna get me wrong like dude
you not done this look you got I would
be like this is how I know dude that's
[ __ ] you saw the adults though it's
totally gone we don't wanna embarrass
got the chick to suck dick onstage at
The Comedy Store huh huh that's how I
walked away from the stage gone oh this
is not good kids here I'm like I can't
be in this yeah yo seriously man doesn't
take where our lunch to grow dreads that
long we're right these are chia pet
seeds if these are jumping on your head
like the [ __ ] dreadlocks bro I'm dead
so if he's a junior with drugs like that
man wrestled as a sophomore with dreads
like that wrestled half a season as a
junior weeks ago with just like that
exactly my point is an adult has to step
in that situation could have been
handled a thousand different ways let's
take this to the back yeah let's
postpone this match let somebody else
wrestle yeah while we target let it
happen
right here you have to cut those dreads
off-camera somewhere so we don't look
stupid because that is a rule
yeah right but because I don't want to
be known as racist guy the rest even
though I'm already known as that right
no have even that yo absolutely that's
just dumb white people out there there's
dumb black people but there's dumb white
people out there dude that just like are
just idiots man like rules are rules but
there's sometimes y'all go what is the
bigger implication right right and what
is I what am I gonna get from enforcing
this particular rule at this particular
time I think sometimes that has to be
taken into account
sure yeah we're gonna enforce this rule
but it doesn't have to be influenced
chick is like you get robbed of her
final year play I mean that's the
problem
no of her college eligibility of her
high school no no she's cool for high
school this is no no I think I are they
saying she can't play high school I mean
no I yet because again like with lamella
ball you're saying like he but he played
professionally so he's ineligible for
college they took him he's playing in
high school now I don't know what's
going on he went back to high school
he's old enough to play in college yet
no he is old enough to play in college
but he's ineligible because they play
professionally over any wherever they
were right right
cuz so much higher some [ __ ] some high
schools weren't taking him back like
they had to find a special high school
for him there's like a traveling
all-star team or unbelievable I heard
he's going to high school for retards
and as bad as there is the principal
yeah how do you like how the Lakers nip
that dude at the [ __ ] yeah that was
good somebody had to well with LeBron
coming you knew it couldn't be that's
another reason I chance like either shut
up or I'll give you aids I'll give you
[ __ ] you know ah so that's it I want
to getting some basketball
I love basket when I get into basketball
yeah I mean like pro NBA
you have this weird things with the NBA
I don't know what it is man but you hate
it
you just said I want to get into
basketball yeah that's all we talked
about for a half hour I mean we can keep
talking about it but yeah no but what do
you want to get into though like what do
you think we're halfway through the
season is this the most exciting year
because you really don't know who's
gonna win no man I think in the world
like I think Boogie Cousins is like
someone who like he hurts chemistry on
the team dude I mean cuz we're looking
at this team that's been a juggernaut
and what is the difference between them
this year and last year when they and
it's like boogie cousin comes in and
just is weird energy man yeah you know
what I felt like that I have that
feeling about certain players but when
Golden State one with JaVale McGee and
swaggy P that's my vibe you know I think
those players matter with Tom it doesn't
matter job I think boogie Cousins is
like a weird kind of like just a like
we're kind of 2010 guys like Oh like
respect me like everything's like like
chemistry's just we I don't know I feel
like he's gonna help them out like you
know I mean you could be right though
but I feel like their chemistry when
they want with JaVale and swag I was
like man chemistry obviously don't
matter with these dudes cuz I never
thought you Velma ghee or swaggy P will
win championships but once once you win
a championship now you're a championship
player on me right so I'm like JaVale
come on we'll we'll roll with me like
look look at look at the New Orleans
dude they technically got better after
he left you know but they were never
good though like he's never been on a
team like this I feel like he's he'll be
able he's gonna be able to fit in with
this culture I wanted the Lakers to get
him so bad I am really amazed they did
do you think LeBron to poopoo that I
don't know cuz I thought when we got
Rondo I thought that was a lot cuz him
and Rondo played together in the world
last year and they were saying Rondo was
one of the ones that really kept him in
check
so I figure when we saw him Rondo boogy
coming to us but he said we didn't even
offer him anything he said Golden State
was the only team
that offered him a contract which is
hard for me to believe me well no I
think the only one that offered him I
think everybody was low-balling well he
only got one year for five million
that's the lowest of the ball me I'm
like we gauge avail more than that
that's ball boy money man who put out
that funniest tweet going dude
I'll know fall if he knows this but like
five mil is like you don't even get a
parking spot in [ __ ] in San Francisco
for that shot that's [ __ ] buggy has
money though you know say he was even
looking like Sacramento's been a little
better since he's left you know New
Orleans like they've just been riddled
like nobody realized like New Orleans
has whoa who's that who's that [ __ ]
guy the guy from Chicago metric or
whatever his name is I can never
remember his name the powerful what
Miocic
that guy's been hurt for two weeks now
like her like I have my fantasy league
for like three weeks he's been out that
guy's a 25 and 10 dude when he plays
with with odd Anthony Davis is a 25 in
10 dude I must say he's probably more
like a 15 nah dude I got my fancy League
you [ __ ]
I know what it is what are you saying
New Orleans should be what in the finals
ooh good dude I mean give us their best
players [ __ ] you know what it is don't
make it would I end up [ __ ] fans no
this is the robbery don't make it a one
eight all right don't get yourself
killed just give up the goods but -
worst fan bases in the world the two
works are [ __ ] Lakers and LeBron dick
suckers and one squad and it's like a
full trying to [ __ ] faces right now
other Patriots fans or worse and Lakers
like everybody give us your best player
we haven't been like that in a minute oh
we
we haven't robbed anyone in a while yeah
you haven't raped raided anyone know
they they nixed our Chris Paul D good
for y'all who's a [ __ ] deal there did
nothing for you guys what do you mean
you guys literally it helped to sell the
[ __ ] franchise for two billion dollar
overpay yo know what Oprah wasn't going
past 1.5 Rob forgot to 1.5 dude huge
about this he's like oh my god about
that he forgot about that
Oprah ain't no sucker opens I got 1.5
for y'all I would love to take that team
off the hands of that racist prick 1.6
I'm out I'm a white power white power
somebody called toilet area oh you know
we haven't talked about because it
happened while we were are we awful
basketball now does that our basketball
talk no we can keep talking about
spokesman go on going what do you want
to talk stat cyborg knockout oh [ __ ]
bye [ __ ] bye [ __ ] bye Felicia bye fish
Lisa that was a knockout but if we had
our big UFC viewing party which those
are super fun so please come to those
we'll do one first are you getting us a
fun I'm into it all right
did you see that doc oh yeah no I didn't
though she knocked that dude out that
dude she says she has no power in her
punches who's I work yeah Amanda Nunes
like dude she has no power
I was excited every fight before this
well it's just like cyborg just like
Rock'em Sock'em robot and like when she
said good like we've seen a couple
fights where again we punch just lands
and it's like oh oh [ __ ] you're in
trouble like Aaron ever had moved listen
there was a punch waiting for her
Anderson Silva vs Chris side Chris Leben
he remember that 13 punches knockout
then when we saw Amanda Nunez vs ronda
rousey or even holly holm vs ronda
rousey's well everything Lant bam bam
blam
LAN LAN just dude think she know how to
[ __ ] go - she got hit no matter what
she dad fighting which is cover up this
[ __ ] is hidden young the hurt must've
felt like she was fighting like an
octopus if each and each arm had a
boxing yeah yeah I mean like so I'm sure
I'll of cyborg that bar when I've had
like cuz she is in traditional pretty
she's had this like kind of build of a
Hama one of her name is cyborg yeah well
she got that from her husband oh you
know so but you know that's her last
name
yeah who always she also got her dick
from her husband I thought that was her
first name yeah one I never see what she
looks like yes she has one eye if that
was your neighbor choose like pick up
your trash cans earlier you'd be like
yes sir I'll shake up yours too exactly
she just couldn't and she just got
knocked the [ __ ] out now the question is
and we've seen this before
with somebody so dominant and then they
get lit up mentally they aren't the same
right what's gonna happen with cyborg is
she gonna be able to come back cuz the
be honest with you I don't know why the
UFC doesn't like her she's just been
undated why yeah you do because they
never wanted her they knew what she
would do to [ __ ] Ronda Rousey they
knew that and they they kept her from
the UFC forever to protect their
billion-dollar blonde you know a cash
cow yeah right she got her ass beat
it's the minute she got her ass beat
they're like oh bring cyborg in every
look just like everybody wanted come on
in just milk this cow yeah just think of
who amanda Nunez has beaten everybody
everybody all of them everybody we just
mentioned she beat all of them yeah it's
unbelievable I mean like I honestly
didn't give her any champ chance
it was cyborg yeah I just like I thought
you would every dog has it that you
thought she's gonna be so I think I
even said that on our last episode hmm
so who does he find next
who does this chick I mean like that's
the problem
I'd say McGregor as I said does she move
up to dudes
yeah how would you like to see a 145
pound woman versus only 120 pound guy no
I'd like to see a 225 male versus a 115
female and I don't care what age you 10
12 whatever yeah I don't think that's
gonna work
yeah I wonder if they would do that
though what a man no no that would be
now that the mo UFC is so Hollywood
right now it's gonna ruin that sport
it's gonna ruin the sport it took us a
hundred years just to have that happen
in tennis you're never gonna have a
sport
you got to do it in some third world
that's the only time and it'll be have
to be so pro team the woman has to be
like so you had the would like she'd be
250 and he has to be like a hundred
pound twin and they're gonna have to win
yeah but it's just it's just like I
don't know where you go I don't know
where you go from there and I really
thought cyborg was somebody you could
drop into the future and she still be
able to compete but now I'm starting to
think that the female game is getting
more and more complex
she's just Rock'em Sock'em right and she
could she never had to change right you
know and that was cool for the first
like delante Wilder if when that guy
loses it's gonna be easy
never gonna become a refined boxer he's
a slugger but if they're not talking
about some in there are 13 versus
somebody in their early 20s or it's like
you could lose in early twenties
I gotta run but you can't eventually you
in a point where like you can't teach an
old dog new tricks no but when you are
so physically gifted over everybody
watching while there isn't 27 no but
that's the thing if you're a heavyweight
and you're a one-trick pony that's a
nice trick to have
right until you meet the prize knock
mother your trick doesn't work on yeah
well he he was a man 18 us doesn't like
magic either cuz she wasn't fall for
that trick
Deontay Wilder hadn't met anyone that
could fight you know saying that what
stood there for 40 fights yeah oh he
didn't lose that fight no it was a drunk
Yeah right right was right by him 40
fights you have a draw yeah you have a
pretty solid that guy out no he got with
that trick yeah
oh he did get our box but steal his
trick almost works sure when he knocked
do dare he did the the light side I got
his dad I thought he was dead
so did Wilder yo like he know he knows
it's like a home run hitter it's like
when you get it and you will see dude I
mean like John Joe Jones yeah it's like
it's like dude do you have anybody in
your life like a great car you know
Cardinals I can talk to you and be like
bro
this is the moment to let your fight you
didn't even you weren't even that it
wasn't even a great fight both I mean
first of all Gustafson can't be black
guys let's just say you can't be black
guys right you just can't you can't just
like and don't bones Jones is black
that's [ __ ] okay doesn't like magic
either okay so John Jones had to come in
and just I feel what just like just
there's a time to be quiet
and just let just fight let the fight
fight and now you remind everybody how
great you weren't even that great we all
know you weren't that great that night
and you were just getting back but
that's part of being a fighter though
you know saying you have to have your
ego like on ten like for comics we gotta
have that for fighters it's even you
know said no one's punching us in the
face you only but we do have
have that level of and see my act I got
punched in the face a lot we have to
have that - getting up on stage by
ourselves man - shut the [ __ ] up before
a boxer's like I always feel like I want
my box around tan yeah after you just
[ __ ] you know was banned for two years
again okay contestant had a mil bite of
whatever right and you made the UFC lied
everybody about that test and there's
this B sample and everything was there
everybody knows you're full of [ __ ] but
it was small enough that they could
fudge it there's B sample okay you got
or you sada John you sada Jones
I would like to UFC to get back to the
base you called that fight UFC 236 be
Sam right so my B sample was cool yeah
yeah blowing me I just we militay you're
saying you're gonna fight this other guy
nobody in fighting doesn't but there
have been a side of the Octagon let's
show some humility
you're lucky to even be working right
now I'm not at ups right you've got so
many strikes against ya no don't be an
[ __ ] right yeah just be quiet be like
you know I mean like when Michael
Bisping who doesn't give a [ __ ] was
interviewing him like he was pressing it
with John Jones and John Jones like just
God you know stop with the god [ __ ] okay
nobody is believing you when you're
citing Bible verses how blessed you are
when you're getting busted cheating
that's what the first thing Dana White's
gotta be like dude work with me here
shut the [ __ ] up about the god stuff
nobody wants to hear about [ __ ] Holy
Roller [ __ ] how blessed you are yeah
well maybe that's what he's using his
turn his life around
dude he's not come on man we all know
who you are okay you know who is
he's he's the champ right yeah
child actor he's a child actor Oh was he
no but he's grew up that way both of his
brothers were in the NFL right but
before he was even fighting their lice
then he became champ at 20 who else did
Tyson he's a child actor he's always in
trouble no one's ever told him no he's
never had to really struggle everything
was given to him it including his
god-given you are physically and
lifestyle genetics superior and yes I'll
say about women who are so goddamn hot
thank you that they make money off their
off that in whatever capacity whether
it's modeling to pornography right
you are crazy there's a little bit of
cuckoo in there whoa the world makes you
like that you don't seem like you're not
well that's true not still true you're
not well that's what they are statements
for I feel like everyone everyone
doesn't get all the way like that but
there's a little bit of that that feeds
in because everyone you're saying
everyone's basically licking your ass
all the time so you're saying as he
makes people crazy yes if you get your
ass eating all the time yeah most feel
really great crazy you need that so I
mean you know again and I can't say how
I would act cuz I ain't never been in
that position but I feel like I will try
having your ass holy all the time I've
had but imagine all the time you're
getting everything you want like you
said that's the child actor syndrome
like you can't be really mad at someone
when s it goes to their head yeah it's
like dude well and but that's to Sam's
point where it's like
oK you've kind of ran this out you're
either gonna mature or you're just gonna
be Johnny Manziel and someone's gonna
take the UFC away from you yeah you're
not the UFC and unfortunately your last
go at this unfortunately that's how it
ends a lot of times and of course Italy
I mean a lot of these child actors I
mean you know it's just it's kind of how
that thing runs its course yeah you're
telling them now to give up something
that they've had all their life exactly
right they're like you know what [ __ ]
that it's in time right here's entitle
and they feel that when I'm a drunk
child actor gets pulled over when
they're 20 they're like do you know who
I don't play for you somebody you have
to ask do you know who I am you are
nobody right bring Sinatra never said
that Elvis never sat down oh dude this
is what I want to show you about I know
we're coming to the end got two minutes
dude have you ever heard that that
Michael Jackson might still be alive
have you seen this [ __ ] no this guy Gary
Gary always have you heard of Gary Gary
oh wait he's still alive he's always
[ __ ] like that though like Tupac is
still alive no but is the weirdest one
dude Michael Jackson huh yeah Gary Gary
Gary Gary where is he supposed to be
okay another country of course no no I
hear he's so white he's doing magic now
he's at the store last night dude you
know what I'm excited for it sports
coming up the new 3430 have you seen a
commercial for it
Deion Sanders when he played baseball
and football on the same day Oh
helicopter copied yeah I do remember
that and don't 3438 I wasn't gonna do
one what about Mike Tyson losing Oh
Buster Douglas yeah yeah I'm great
right one man do you remember where you
were when that happened yes I was at my
mom's yeah everybody our age or but I
don't I don't even I want to say it
wasn't even paper or maybe it was paper
you it was HBO but it came on early
that's right it was in Japan so it came
on it wasn't like the regular late you
know eight o'clock Mike Tyson's most
weird yeah yeah there's something like
that from us I think it was early in the
morning but it was just kind of like
like he caught you our obviously talked
you off guard divorce yeah I had it on
in the background like I'm just gonna
watch him get murdered right but I'm not
really and then that's round by round
where and that's the thing is it started
being like oh he might lose it how great
a fight down no that's what I'm gonna
say cuz you're like Oh Tyson might lose
but then he not Buster Douglas down
right okay here we go
but then Buster Douglas got up my mom
just died Oh God he had that kind of
like I don't I didn't remember that I
didn't either
at that time I didn't remember that his
mom had just passed and it's one of
those fights which been so long since it
happened you just remember Tyson getting
knocked out right I mean you can't
you're like [ __ ] this was a good fight
got how good of a [ __ ] fight that way
and these and the times like what was
going around all around now how big
Tyson was because they were short some
of his previous fights Trump would be at
his fights oh yeah I was like damn right
right but that was that Robin Givens
[ __ ] that's that was right we thought
true no you're evil when people feel bad
for Mike Tyson on how you treated him
right no right no absolutely like like
she played her cards all wrong right
well she got it from her mama Donna paid
supposedly her mama gave Dave Parker the
herb remember the baseball player and
ace and they supposedly he was do I'm
all these rooms I should be room or
naughty today but supposedly he was the
one that him and Canseco got those aids
on roids
he was he looking Dave Parker
well katenka was the ringleader but
suppose one day Parker
you don't saying he was at the end of
his career I never got busted for any of
that though I mean I'm not saying it's
not true but ya know he did no they
never commenting on that he's going
Island fine he went out right then like
that was towards the end of his career
you know I'm saying and it was just
starting up really yeah because you know
eighties right into the night on no it
was that the ad 18 that the Dodgers beat
that was such a juggernaut when Kirk
Gibson hit their home yeah yeah how
great that was the first year of their
real Roy yummy and that was his last
year he was on that team yeah Dave
Parker was on no no no we're saying the
roids the steroid generation those feel
feeling there there's Mike Mike in
between the adjustables reliable source
Jim boy being Michael Jackson still
alive everybody right and he was at the
store last night man it was a line it
was a line the line was Green it was a
[ __ ] green so we got Schubert in next
week I told him bring some magic tricks
yeah why not you're not the only person
to get passed at The Comedy Store and
magic oh yeah so when I did a big show
at The Comedy Store comedy chaos he was
back there and then Bronson who owns the
house of comedies in Arizona Minneapolis
Rick yeah he does magic too so he was in
the back and Jimmy was doing magic and
he's like I'll let me see your mouth and
he states they started having a magic
off and I was like oh [ __ ] magician off
they were battling yeah right they had a
magic battle I love him the Bronson's
are good people too
super good good people so with Jimmy
Schubert Jimmy super good guy
whoa I think we've made some progress in
regulation I didn't say I like magic
we're just standing there and like so I
see his car - so I'm next to him so
we're kind of like not a team but like I
he showed me his car so I knew what it
was and then it goes through the whole
thing this and then cuts it up and pulls
his car down he goes [ __ ] this magic
let's flip flops and just bang black
strippers all the time with my magic
yeah they think you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
wizard you need that other magic at this
trick who was it that had a great job I
think might be Cedric the Entertainer
had this great joke about whenever like
a bunch of black people stand around
each other if one of them starts running
the other won't even ask a question they
just everybody runs yeah we're taking
his word for going on why why people
want to go investigate let's see where
that shooting is coming from
I hear gunshot there was that shoot it's
shooting at the store that's similar
what happened cuz I was just coming
around the corner you know I'd the belly
room center that says comics all right I
was rounding the corner mm-hmm and
everybody was caught in that way just a
look on everybody's faces said go right
with them no I was that went the whole I
went oh you ran right but I'm saying
whatever way they're running I'm going
yeah yeah yeah
don't go opposite of yeah yeah yeah yeah
now that's a good way to run there's a
reason everybody I'm looking at has a
maze of an adrenaline dump right you
know I mean they're scared of something
that's that's crazy I'm running out of
gas right now so well that's perfect
time because it's one o'clock everybody
is it
Wow Wow final thoughts thanks
all right that was good enough I'll be
on the dark side of the moon about 10
minutes anyone want to join me I don't
even know what that means people that
knows that we people that need to know
that means we can hi guys thank you guys
so much and I will Jimmy Schubert
actually Schubert next week follow me on
like the ground mallow cream onion cream
back and just watch black people's mind
get bombed yeah now if it's gonna be
magic mamuh be outside okay
[Laughter]